THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA
.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA. CAM
LAGER DOES.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY. MEDINA.
MELENDEZ
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE EIGHTEEN.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON. WEBER.
WOULD. MISTER SPEAKER
THERE'S A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
FATHER DEBTS HAVE HARBORED
UNION.
HE IS THE.
ARCH PRIESTS PARISH PRIEST AND
VICAR OF NORTH AMERICA WESTERN
DIOCESE OF THE ARMENIAN CHURCH
OF NORTH AMERICA FATHER.
WELL NO.
GATHERED HERE TODAY IN THE STATE
CAPITAL.
OUR INDIVIDUALS SELECTED TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
BY GOD'S WILL MADE DAY HAVE THE
STRENGTH AND FORTITUDE.
TO BE GOOD STEWARDS OF THE LAND.
AND PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ENTRUSTED TO IT.
IN THIS BODY OLDIES WHO ARE
ENTRUSTED WITH THE GOD GIVEN
MISSION.
TO SERVE HUMANITY AND TO BRING
JUSTICE
TO THE PEOPLE'S LIVE WITH THE
VISION OF RESPECT IN OLD TEAMS
INCLUDING HISTORY.
TODAY WE OFFER OUR PRAYERS TO
THE ALL MIGHTY INTO MEMBERS OF
THE VICTIMS SO THERE FOR US
GENOCIDE. OF TWENTIETH CENTURY.
PERPETRATED BY THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE AGAINST ARMENIAN PEOPLE.
WE GIVE HEARTFELT THANKS THAT
OUR GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALONG WITH FORTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES CONTINUE TO PROCLAIM
THE TRUTH OF THESE CRIME AGAINST
HUMANITY.
LED DISPLAY BE A SPECIAL MOMENT
FOR US.
TO COMMEMORATE THE MARTIN SENSE
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
LET THIS MOMENT ESTABLISH WITHIN
OUR HEARTS.
SPEED OF OUR FOREFATHERS TO
UPHOLD THEIR CULTURAL AND
SPIRITUAL HERITAGE.
LED THEIR LEGACY INSPIRED US TO
BECOME RESPECTFUL CITIZENS OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IN
PURSUING JUSTICE.
IN ALL MATTERS BY THE SPECIALLY
FOR THE ARMENIAN CLOSE.
FOR THE WOES INTEGRATES STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT MANY OF OUR A
SENSE ASSESS THE PHONES.
MANIFOLD BLESSINGS
WHEN DAY'S SALT REAP HUGE DURING
THE TIME OF GREAT TRAGEDY*
DRIVE.
HE'D OUR PRAYERS TO LORDS AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA GROUND THEM
ALL WHO IS THEM. AND PRESERVE
AROUNDS TO CONTINUE TO OBSERVE.
OF ABDEL TWENTY FOUR. HOURS A
DAY OVER MEMBERS OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
LED THEIR COLLEGE SERVER WAS A
SHINING EXAMPLE. TO ALL THOSE
WHO HAVE YET TO AFFIRM THE TRUTH
OF HISTORY.
FINALLY ONLY T. AND BENEFICIAL
LORD WE PRAY THAT YOUR LOVE AND
GRACE
GUARD Q. MINDED DE.
INTO THE BRIGHTER FUTURE.
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED THE LESSON
OF OUR? PROCESS.
AND DEVOTED OURSELVES TO MUTUAL
PEACE.
AND
A COLD.
A MAN.
THANK YOU FATHER PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING.
BEFORE OUR FLAG SALUTE THE WHOLE
MINUTEMEN SCOUTS WILL PRESENT
THE COLORS PLEASE PRESENT THE
COLORS
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ACOSTA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER ACOSTA.
THANK YOU SPEAKER. LATER AHEAD
OF YOUR HEART JOIN ME IN
PLEDGING TO THE FLAG OF OUR
GREAT COUNTRY.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
ZERO.
PRETTY INTERESTING
.
YOU MAY BE SEATED
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL
ELEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
SEMI MINUTES SEVEN A. M. ON A
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIRTY FIRST AT PRESIDING CHIEF
LACKEY DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
FOR THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BILL QUIRK.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HIS AREA TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. SOMEONE MEMBERS
HEARINGS GAS WILL BE SEATED IN
THE AREA THE MEMBERS DESKS
AND AT THE ROSTRUM FOR THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE REMEMBRANCE
CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KILEY WOULD AND FRIEDMAN
TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GET
TODAY.
I RECOGNIZE A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS HOUSE SITTING AT MY DESK.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER CACHO A
SHOT HERE AND GOOD TO SEE YOU
SIR ARE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION TO MR
PEROT. FOR YOUR GAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY ON THE ON.
SCHOOL GROUP FROM LAGUNA WOODS.
THE GENEVA SCHOOL.
CHRISTIAN BASED CLASSICAL STYLE
EDUCATION SCHOOL. AND.
PLEASE HAVE THEM WELCOME A TO
THE STATE CAPITOL THERE'S.
EVERY CHILD IS SPECIAL THERE
HAPPENS TO BE ONE IN THE SCHOOL
IT'S VERY SPECIAL TO ME. MY
DAUGHTER KAELIN SO WELCOME TO
THE CAPITAL
.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
OPEN THE GALLERY UP TO MY RIGHT
IN THE BACK.
I HAD THE BACK A BILL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION WHO HAS
ALWAYS HAD A STRONG CONNECTION
TO THE COMMUNITY.
THAT IT SERVES
IT TOOK TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
ASSOCIATION ESTABLISHED THE BACK
CITY FIREFIGHTERS CHARITY FUND
TO LEND A HELPING HAND. TO THE
COMMUNITY.
THESE AMAZING FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
RAISED NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OVER THESE PAST FIVE YEARS.
THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN DONATED TO
ASSIST UNDER FUNDED PROGRAMS
SUCH AS TEEN CENTERS SCHOOLS.
CANCER ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS
LOCAL YOUTH GROUPS SENIOR
CITIZENS AND VICTIMS OF VARIOUS
TRAGEDIES.
WE ARE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
OUR MILITARY.
ORGAN ORGANIZATIONS THE
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE CONTRIBUTE TO
HAVE BEEN THE BOOK THAT IS NOT
TO BUILD BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY ASSOCIATION'S
FILL THE BOOT BASKETS OF HOPE
SAME BALDRICK'S NORTH BAY
WOMEN'S HEALTH RESOURCE CENTER.
THAT KILLED BOBBY SOCKS BACK
WILL HIGH SCHOOL BASEBALL AND
MANY MANY MORE.
JUST WANT TO INTRODUCE THEM AS
A.
CHAMPION FOR THE DISADVANTAGED
IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND.
I WANT TO SHOW MY APPRECIATION
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES.
THAT A FIRE FIGHTING AGENCY HAS
SET THE BAR AND CHALLENGES THAT
MANY FIREFIGHTERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT
TO DO THE SAME THANK YOU BACK A
BILL FIREFIGHTERS A WELCOME
.
AND MR MATHIS YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE.
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO YOU TODAY.
CUB SCOUT PACK NINETEEN TWENTY.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST.
ALL GIRL COME SCOUT PACK.
THE CUT.
YES CLASS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE RIGHT UP THERE
IN THE GALLERY.
THE CUB SCOUTS CELEBRATE.
IT'S A HUNDRED NINETEENTH
ANNIVERSARY THIS YEAR. AND BY
OPENING IT ITSELF TO BOTH BOYS
AND GIRLS ACROSS THE NATION.
IT IS MODERNIZED ITS EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE FAMILY UNITY.
AN AMERICAN SCOUTING.
MY SON A CUB SCOUT PACK NINETEEN
TWENTY. IS THE VERY FIRST ALL
GIRL CUB SCOUT PACK TO FORMING
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO CELEBRATE
THIS MILESTONE.
RODNEY BLOCK GO.
A FRIEND OF MINE AND A FATHER
FOR ADVICE CILIA SOUGHT TO
ESTABLISH AN ALL GIRL. CUB SCOUT
PACK FOR HIS DAUGHTER ME EVEN TO
GET.
IT ONLY SEEMED APPROPRIATE YOU
TOLD ME TO DESIGNATE THE FACT
NINETEEN TWENTY.
AFTER THE YEAR IN WHICH AMERICAN
WOMEN GAINED THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
TODAY THE CUB SCOUTS CONTINUE.
TO TEACH AMERICA'S YOUTH ABOUT
LEADERSHIP.
INCLUSIVITY.
AND MAKING GOOD LIFE CHOICES.
AS A PROUD SCOTT MYSELF.
I THINK IT'S KEY EACH REMEMBER.
THAT IN SCOUTING.
WE PLEDGE.
TO DO OUR BEST TO DO OUR DUTY TO
GOD AND OUR COUNTRY.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING.
CUB SCOUT PACK NINETEEN TWENTY
TO THE STATE CAPITOL
.
AND MR ACOSTA YOU HAVE GUESTS
TODAY.
YES I DO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND A DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS AND GAS.
WONDERFUL DATE TODAY LA WHERE WE
HAVE OUR.
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES HERE WITH
US TODAY BUT WE HAVE SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS FOR MY DISTRICT
ALSO. RELATED TO A FORMER MEMBER
OF SET NOW SENATOR SCOTT WOKE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER HIS
BEAUTIFUL BRIDE.
VANESSA WILL BEST DISAPPOINTING
LOCUSTS IN THE RACK ALONG WITH
HER MOTHER ALICE APPOINTED. MOM
STAND UP BALLOTS WAVED EVERYBODY
IF YOU'D ALL PLEASE WELCOME THEM
HERE TO THE CHAMBER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMING WITH TODAY
.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SPECIAL CEREMONY.
IN REMEMBRANCE.
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF
NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
THIS YEAR MARKS THE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRD ANNIVERSARY.
OF THIS TRAGEDY.
WE WILL MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE.
THAT IS A J. OUR THIRTY SEVEN.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE THIRD
READING MS FRIEDMAN ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IT BEGAN ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
FOR EIGHT LONG YEARS THE
ARMENIAN NATION WAS SUBJECTED TO
A SYSTEMATIC AND PREMEDITATED
GENOCIDE AT THE HANDS OF THE
OTTOMAN TURKISH EMPIRE AND THE
REPUBLIC OF TURKEY.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE WHO OR
THESE VICTIMS THEY WERE FATHERS
MOTHERS?
SISTERS AND BROTHERS IN
CHILDREN.
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ARMENIAN
LIVES WERE LOST
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ASSYRIANS GREEKS HAD OTHER
CHRISTIANS PERISHED IN ONE OF
THE MOST ATROCIOUS VIOLATIONS OF
HUMAN RIGHTS HISTORY.
THIS WAS THE FIRST GENOCIDE.
TWENTIETH CENTURY.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN MOST
ARMENIANS KNEW SOMEBODY WHO WAS
A THEMSELVES OR SURVIVOR. OR A
DIRECT DESCENDANT OF A SURVIVOR
BUT NOW THAT WERE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE YEARS LATER.
THOSE SURVIVORS THEMSELVES OF
COURSE ARE FADING.
AND IN SOME CASES THE MEMORIES
OF THAT GENOCIDE.
FADING.
BUT NOT AMONGST THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR WORK NOT
HEARING CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY A HUNDRED AND THREE
YEARS LATER WE ARE HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR TODAY TO REMEMBER
THOSE LIVES LOST.
THOSE HOPES THOSE DREAMS THOSE
LOVES.
ALL.
TAKEN AWAY DURING THIS VERY DARK
PERIOD IN TWENTIETH CENTURY
HISTORY.
AS WE PAY OUR SOLEMN TRIBUTE TO
THE VICTIMS OF THESE UNSPEAKABLE
CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY. LET'S
REMEMBER THAT WERE ALSO HERE TO
RENEW OUR VOW.
TO NEVER LET IT HAPPEN AGAIN.
TO NEVER BE THE BYSTANDER THAT
STANDS IDLY BY. AS GENOCIDE
HAPPENS.
AS THE LEGISLATIVE BODY IN
ELECTED LEADERS IT'S OUR DUTY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR NATION AND OUR
WORLD RECOGNIZE THE GENOCIDE FOR
WHAT IT WAS.
DENYING THE ATROCITIES ARE
REMAINING SILENT INVITES
REOCCURRENCE.
OUR MODERN HISTORY IS SADLY FULL
OF EXAMPLES OF THE PERILS OF
SILENCE.
LESS THEN A DECADE AFTER THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WHICH BY THE
WAY WAS REPORTED ABOUT AN
AMERICAN NEWSPAPERS IN THERE
WERE EVEN FAMOUS AMERICAN
EFFORTS TO HELP VICTIMS OF THE
GENOCIDE.
SO LESS THAN A DECADE LATER.
HITLER DEVELOP HIS PLANS FOR THE
HOLOCAUST AND REASSURED HIS
COMMANDERS THAT THEY WOULD NOT
FACE RETRIBUTION.
HE DECLARED WHO AFTER ALL
SPEAKS.
TODAY OF THE ANNIHILATION OF THE
ARMENIANS.
EVEN TODAY THOSE PERPETRATORS OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
WE'RE NEVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
REPARATIONS WERE NEVER FULLY
MADE NEVER MADE IT ALL BY THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT TO THOSE
VICTIMS.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
REMIND CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD
THAT WOULD WITH ANY GROUP IS
MARGINALIZED OR DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST WE ALL HAVE A DUTY TO
SPEAK UP TO PUSH BACK IN THE
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
SO THAT NO ONE WILL KNOW THE
PAIN. THAT OUR ANCESTORS DID.
AND SPEAKING OUT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE
JUST YESTERDAY OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE GATHER IN YOUR
VAN TO PROTEST.
UNDEMOCRATIC ACTIONS BY THE
ARMENIAN GOVERNMENT.
I'M VERY PROUD THAT IN MY CITY
OF GLENDALE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TOOK TO THE STREETS IN
SOLIDARITY.
WITH THEIR BROTHERS AND SISTER
IN ARMENIA.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT. THOSE VOICES
MATTERED.
JUST THIS MORNING THE GOVERNMENT
ANNOUNCED CHANGES.
THAT WILL MAKE ARMENIA.
THE DEMOCRACY THAT ITS PEOPLE
WANTED TO BE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF THOSE BRAVE VOICES WHO STOOD
UP.
IT'S OUR DUTY TO DO THE SAME
HERE.
AND TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE IN CALLING
FOR WORLDWIDE RECOGNITION OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE DONE THIS
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND YET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AMERICA HAS
YET TO OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE FOR WHAT IT WAS.
BUT I KNOW THAT JUST AS THOSE
ARMENIAN VOICES.
GOT.
THE DEMOCRACY THEY CALLED FOR.
THAT WE WILL GET THAT WORLDWIDE
RECOGNITION FOR THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
QUIET.
IN LOS ANGELES ON MARCH THAT
USED TO HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
NOW HAS OVER A MILLION PEOPLE
EVERY YEAR TO COMMEMORATE
GENOCIDE AND TURKEY WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO IGNORE THOSE
VOICES BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY. AND THAT IS THE
BEGINNING OF JUSTICE.
BECAUSE OF THAT I ASK YOU ALL TO
PLEASE JOIN ME.
NOT JUST VOTING I ON THIS
RESOLUTION BUT IN COAUTHOR RING
IT'S THAT WE HAVE A UNITED AND
LOUD VOICE SAYING THAT JUSTICE
CANNOT BE DENIED. THAT THOSE
VICTIMS WERE NOT REST IN PEACE
UNTIL THIS GENOCIDE IS
RECOGNIZED AROUND THE WORLD FOR
WHAT IT WAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU MEMBERS.
DAVIS REMAIN MISTER HOLDING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS LEGISLATION AG OUR
THIRTY SEVEN ARISE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
WHICH DESIGNATES ABLE TWENTY
FOUR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS A
HUNDRED AND THIRD ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
I APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF
ARMENIAN AMERICANS AROUND THE
WORLD FOR THEIR PURSUIT OF TRUTH
AND JUSTICE FOR THE ARMENIAN.
COMMUNITY.
THEIR CAUSE IS THE SAME PURSUIT
OF TRUTH AND JUSTICE FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS EVERYWHERE.
JUST AS DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR WON SAID.
AN INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A
THREAT.
TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE ARMENIANS
UNDER THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE IS NOT
THAT DIFFERENT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
SLAVES OR NATIVE AMERICANS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
DESPITE GENOCIDE AND ETHNIC
CLEANSING WE SEE THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS REALIZE THE
ATROCITIES OF THE PAST AND
FIGHT.
FOR A BETTER FUTURE.
WE REMEMBER THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE TODAY WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO FIGHTING SYSTEMATIC
INJUSTICE AND INEQUALITY BY
GOVERNMENTS EVERYWHERE. AND JOIN
THEIR CAUSE TO STOP FUTURE
GENOCIDES.
AT THE SAME TIME WE CAN
CELEBRATE LIFE AFTER THE COURAGE
TO SURVIVE.
TODAY CALIFORNIA'S THE HOME TO
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
ARMENIANS
FOUR THOUSAND OF WHICH RESIDE IN
MY DISTRICT AND CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR ECONOMY.
THROUGH LITERATURE CULTURE.
AND VISUAL ARTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS HOLDING.
MR ACOSTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE AS WELL FOR US ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN
AND I RISE IN SUPPORT OF I A WAS
PSALM.
RAISED IN GRANADA HILLS A LARGE
ARMENIAN POPULATION THERE AT THE
TIME AND I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT.
OF THE THIRTY EIGHTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
ARMENIAN POPULATION. AND HAVING
JUST RECENTLY.
BEEN TO ARMENIA VISITED THE
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL THAT'S THERE
YOU IT IS A STARK EXAMPLE IN A
MOVIE EXAMPLE OF THE DEPRAVITY
OF MAN. AGAINST ANOTHER GROUP OF
IF PEOPLE THAT.
BECAUSE OF HATRED.
ANIMUS AND OTHER REASONS I
STAND WITH MY COLLEAGUES TODAY.
ASKING YOU TO ALL RECOGNIZE WHAT
CAN HAPPEN WIN THE WORLD TURNS
ITS BACK ON A PEOPLE.
AND ALTHOUGH WE'RE TALKING A
HUNDRED THREE YEARS AGO IT COULD
BE YESTERDAY COULD BE TOMORROW.
AND I WANT TO REMIND US ALL THAT
WE NEED TO STAND FOR FOUR OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ARE SUFFERING
SUCH ATROCITIES ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD PARTICULARLY RIGHT HERE IN
OUR IN OUR BACKYARD I STAND WITH
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE.
I STAND WITH.
ARC MY COLLEAGUES TODAY AND I
JUST ASKED WE CONTINUE TO ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AMOS ACOSTA DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
TO ALSO SPEAK A IN SUPPORT OF AG
OUR THIRTY SEVEN TO THINK MY.
ELOQUENT COLLEAGUE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. THAT WITH EACH
YEAR PASSING WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE ATROCITIES AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT IT BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THINGS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
IT. AND WELL.
MANY MANY PEOPLE WERE MURDERED
OFTEN THE TARGETS OF THE WEAPONS
OF WAR ARE TAKEN UP AGAINST
WOMEN.
WHAT IS SURELY KILLED BUT ARE
RAPED ARE BRANDED ARE FORCED TO
LIVE AS SEX SLAVES AND FORCED
WIVES WITH THE FLAGS OF THE
OPPRESSORS TATTOOED ON THEIR
FACES AND HANDS?
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T KEPT WHICH
THAT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD AND KNOW HOW MANY WOMEN
WERE KILLED BUT WE DO KNOW SO
MANY OF THEM AFTER THEIR
HUSBANDS AND CHILDREN AND UNCLES
AND FATHERS WERE MARCHED OFF AND
KILLED. WERE FORCED TO LIVE WITH
THE OPPRESSORS EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND BEAR THE.* OF THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
EVERYWHERE I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AG OUR THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AJ OUR
THIRTY SEVEN.
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO THE
WORLD WITNESSED THE SLAUGHTER OF
ONE AND A HALF MILLION ARMENIAN
MEN WOMEN. AND CHILDREN WHO WERE
EXILED FROM THEIR HISTORIC
HOMELAND.
THE U. S. AMBASSADOR TO THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE HENRY MORGAN
THOU.
DOCUMENTED THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
EXTENSIVELY
AND RAISE SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO
ASSIST THE VICTIMS IN THE
AFTERMATH.
BY HELPING LAUNCH THE NEAR EAST
RELIEF.
THIS CONGRESSIONALLY CHARTERED
HUMANITARIAN ORGANIZATION
CREATED A SPECIAL BOND BETWEEN
AMERICANS IN THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE
WHICH CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
THIS BOND IS PARTICULARLY STRONG
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEEK JUSTICE FOR THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WE CELEBRATE THE
SURVIVAL. OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
GOVERNMENT.
BUSINESSES.
ARTS.
AND CULTURE.
I WOULD LIKE T RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE
WESTERN REGION THE MOST
POWERFUL.
ARMENIAN AMERICAN GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION FROM THE FOR THE
IMPORTANT WORK THEY DO BY
EDUCATING AND PREPARING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS TO
ADVOCATE ON ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE
TO THEIR COMMUNITY. THE LATINO
CAUCUS IS PROUD TO SUPPORT AJ
OUR THIRTY SEVEN AS WE REAFFIRM
OUR COMMITMENT TO PROMOTING
HUMAN RIGHTS AND ABDIC
ADVOCATING FOR JUSTICE. IN DOING
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
OUR LEADERSHIP ROLE IN BUILDING
A MORE TOLERANT SOCIETY. AND A
MORE PEACEFUL WORLD THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO CO
AUTHOR.
THEY MUCH CALDERON MISTER GLORIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HR
THIRTY SEVEN IN COMMEMORATION OF
THE ONE HUNDRED THIRD
ANNIVERSARY. OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED ON THE TWENTY FOURTH
OF APRIL SINCE THE NINETEEN
TWENTIES.
IT IS ON THIS TRAGIC DAY. IN
HISTORY THAT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN A
OF OUR MEAN DESCENT LOST THEIR
LIVES.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS OF
THIS RESOLUTION IN PARTICULAR
THE SOME OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE AS WELL AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY.
TO PUT THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
MAKING SURE THIS ISSUE IS NOT
LOST UPON THIS BODY AND ITS
MEMBERS.
AND CALLING UPON ALL OF US TO
COMMEMORATE THE HISTORY BEHIND
THE HORRENDOUS EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED BETWEEN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE.
ON THIS DAY WE REMEMBER THE
VICTIMS AND WE ARE REMINDED THAT
WE MUST STAND TOGETHER AGAINST
THE DANGERS THAT AIM TO SEPARATE
PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR RACE.
THEIR RELIGION THEIR POLITICAL
VIEWS OR THEIR CULTURES.
ON BEHALF OF ATI LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE AND WE
URGE SUPPORT OF AJ OUR THIRTY
SEVEN.
IN COMMEMORATION OF THE ONE
HUNDRED THIRD ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE THANK YOU
SPEAK.
THANK I MISS GLORIA MISTER
LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AJ
OUR THIRTY SEVEN. IT'S A DAY
TODAY THAT WE REMEMBER THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND WE HONOR
THOSE WHOSE LIVES WERE BRUTALLY
TAKEN IN THE FIRST GENOCIDE OF
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY. LAST WEEK
DURING THE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
AND TODAY WE HEARD.
THE WORDS.
THAT MIGHT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR COLLEAGUE
FROM GLENDALE MENTIONED THAT
HITLER SAID UPON HIS INVASION OF
OAKLAND AND AS HE EMBARKS UPON
THE FINAL SOLUTION TO
EXTERMINATE. THE WORLD'S JEWS
WHEN HE SAID WHO AFTER ALL
SPEAKS TODAY. OF THE
ANNIHILATION OF THE ARMENIANS.
WE DO.
WE SPEAK TODAY WE SPEAK IN
UNISON TO COMMEMORATE AND
REMEMBER THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION. ARMENIANS THAT WERE
KILLED DURING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
PLEASE JOIN US IN SUPPORTING HR
THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVIN MISTER
NAZARIAN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IS YOU ARE THIRTY SEVEN
COMMEMORATES
A HUNDRED AND THIRD ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND
CALLS UPON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FORMALLY.
CONSISTENTLY REAFFIRMED THE
HISTORICAL TRUTH THAT THE
ATROCITIES COMMITTED AGAINST THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE CONSTITUTED
GENOCIDE.
THIS RESOLUTION PACE HOMMAGE TO
THE ONE AND A HALF MILLION
VICTIMS. THAT WERE SYSTEMICALLY
KILLED AT THE HANDS OF THE
OTTOMAN TURKISH EMPIRE.
THEN THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY.
MEMBERS I DON'T FEEL A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO COMMEMORATE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BECAUSE I'M
SIMPLY ETHNICALLY ARMENIAN.
GENOCIDE AFFECTS MORE THAN JUST
THE VICTIMS.
IT TRANSCENDS AND CARRIES
THROUGH TO IMPACT GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
IT IS A HUMANISTIC FEATURE WHICH
POUNDS OF SALT. COLLECTIVELY WE
CARRY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
RECOGNIZE AND CALL OUT IN JUST
THIS WHEN WE SEE IT.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT ONE AND A
HALF MILLION PEOPLE.
IT'S HARD TO CAPTURE WHAT THAT
NUMBER REALLY MEANS.
PRIOR TO THE GENOCIDE THERE WERE
TWO MILLION ARMENIANS LIVING IN
THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE.
WITHIN A SHORT TIME. THREE
QUARTERS OF AN ANCIENT
CIVILIZATION PERISHED.
THE LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES DESTROYED
ONE AND A HALF MILLION PARENTS
SONS AND DAUGHTERS GONE AN
ANCIENT LINEAGE.
NEARLY WAS OBLITERATED.
COLLEAGUES IT IS TIME TO SAY
NEVER FORGET.
BUT IT'S CRUCIAL TO TELL THE
STORIES OF THE VICTIMS AND THOSE
WHO.
WITNESS THE CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY.
THE FRENCH WRITER MILAN KUNDERA
WROTE.
STRUGGLE OF MAN AGAINST POWER IS
THE STRUGGLE OF MEMORY AGAINST
FOR GETTING.
THE AMERICAN AMBASSADOR OF THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE AND TURKEY AT THE
TIME.
MISTER HENRY MORGENTHAU.
WITNESS THESE ATROCITIES AND
URGE THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT TO
INTERVENE.
HE OUTLINED A CHILLING DETAILS.
AND SAID THE FOLLOWING HOMES
WERE LITERALLY UPROOTED MEN
KILLED WOMEN AND GIRLS VIOLATED.
DAILY.
HE CONTINUED TO EXPLAIN HOW
ORDERS WERE GIVEN THE GOVERNOR'S
OF PROVINCES TO SEND INTO EXILE.
THE ENTIRE ARMENIAN POPULATION
IRRESPECTIVE OF AGE AND SEX.
CHILDREN WERE THROWN INTO THE
RIVERS.
IN REFLECTING ON THE WORLD'S
FAILURE TO ACT DECISIVELY
AGAINST THE GENOCIDE.
HE ASKED.
WILL DEFINITELY STEPS THE
PROBABLY TAKEN TO RESCUE
PERMANENTLY THE REMNANTS OF
THESE FINE OLD CIVILIZED. PEOPLE
FROM TURKS.
HUNDRED YEARS LATER WE'RE STILL
ASKING SIMILAR QUESTIONS IN THAT
VERY SAME REGION.
CHANGE THE PLAYERS.
IN FACT IT WAS AMBASSADOR
MORGENTHAU'S PERSONAL TELEGRAM
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE IN
WASHINGTON.
IN SEPTEMBER NINETEEN FIFTEEN
THAT SPARKED THE AMERICAN LED
RELIEF CAMPAIGN.
WHICH WAS NOTED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM MONTEBELLO.
THE NEAR EASTERN RELIEF WHICH
HELP SAVE MORE THAN MILLION
ARMENIAN LIVES.
AND OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND ORPHANS WERE FOUND
ALL THROUGHOUT THE DESERT'S AND
THAT'S WHAT ACTUALLY RECREATED
THE ARMENIAN STATE.
I CAN'T HELP BUT TO REMEMBER TO
POINT AND WORDS OF DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. WHEN HE SO
ACCURATELY STATED IN THE END WE
WILL REMEMBER NOT THE WORDS OF
OUR ENEMIES. BUT THE SILENCE OF
OUR FRIENDS.
RESPECT THE FIGHT THAT IS SEND
THIS BACK BEFORE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT A CENTURY. HAS PASSED
SINCE THIS HORRIFIC CRIME
AGAINST HUMANITY. MANY.
OUR SPEAKING UP AND ON BEHALF OF
THE JOBS JUST BECAUSE OF
ARMENIANS.
THE ARE SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THE
INABILITY TO HEAL WOUNDS.
ABOUT THE PURSUIT OF JUSTICE
ABOUT MANKIND'S INDIFFERENCE TO
THE UNSPEAKABLE SUFFERING OF AN
INNOCENT PEOPLE. THEY'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT DENIAL. FROM
EVERY CORNER OF THE WORLD FROM
EUROPE TO ASIA TO AMERICA THEY
SPEAKING ABOUT DENIAL.
POPE FRANCIS SAID IT BEST WHEN
HE STATED CONCEALING OR DENYING
EVIL IS LIKE ALLOWING A WOUND.
I KEEP BLEEDING WITHOUT
BANDAGING IT.
THE MESSAGE HAS NEVER BEEN
CLEAR.
STATEMENTS STATEMENTS SUCH AS
THESE REPRESENT WHAT ARMENIANS
HAVEN'T TOURED SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTEEN. AT THE COST OF GENOCIDE
DENIAL.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR THE
PERPETRATORS OF THIS HEINOUS
ATROCITY TO ACCEPT THEIR PAST.
AND BEGIN THE SLOW PAINFUL
PROCESS OF HEALING.
THE PROCESS BEGINS WITH CALLING
WHAT OCCURRED A HUNDRED YEARS
AGO BY ITS NAME.
GENOCIDE.
THE LEADERS OF TURKEY TODAY DENY
THAT GENOCIDE EVER TOOK PLACE.
BY ATTEMPTING TO CONCEAL THE
TRUTH AND BY CONTINUING TO USE
RHETORIC THAT SUGGEST THEY ARE
UNWILLING TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THEIR
BLOODY PAST IT IS CLEAR THEY
INTEND TO CARRY ON THE SAME
APPROACH FOR THE NEXT HUNDRED
YEARS.
UNTIL AND UNLESS THE ARE
PRESSURED TO COME TO TERMS WITH
THEIR HISTORY OPENLY AND
HONESTLY.
WHEN PRETTY PRESIDENT ERDOGAN
CONDEMNED THE POPE'S STATEMENT.
A FEW YEARS AGO.
AND WARNED HIM NOT TO MAKE
SIMILAR MISTAKES AGAIN.
IS THE HEAD OF A STATE.
SPOKE VOLUMES ABOUT TURKEY'S
PLANS TO ACCEPT ITS OWN HISTORY
AND THE COUNTRY'S PLANS FOR
GENUINE RECONCILIATION.
I JUST LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH
THE WORDS OF A SILLY GROSSMAN A
SURVIVOR WHO LOST HIS MOTHER
DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
I HAVE SEEN THAT IT IS NOT MAN
WHO IS IMPOTENT.
IN THE STRUGGLE AGAINST EVIL.
BUT THE POWER OF EVIL. THAT IS
IMPOTENT IN THE STRUGGLE AGAINST
MEN.
POWERLESSNESS OF KINDNESS
OF SENSELESS KINDNESS.
IS THE SECRET OF ITS
IMMORTALITY.
IT CAN NEVER BE CONQUERED.
HUMAN HISTORY IS NOT THE BATTLE
OF GOOD STRUGGLING OVER TO
OVERCOME EVIL.
IT IS A BATTLE FOUGHT BY A GREAT
EVIL.
STRUGGLING TO CRUSH A SMALL
KERNEL.
OF HUMAN KINDNESS.
BUT IF WHAT IS HUMAN IN HUMAN
BEINGS HAS NOT BEEN DESTROYED
EVEN NOW.
THEN EVIL WILL NEVER CONQUER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED
ON THE RESOLUTION.
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES FOR ADDING THEIR
VOICES TODAY IS A LOT OF THINGS
THAT I'M PROUD OF.
ABOUT MY DISTRICT AND THE TOP
THING THAT I'M MOST PROUD OF IS
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF ARMENIANS OUTSIDE
OF THE COUNTRY OF ARMENIA.
AND.
OF ALL THE THINGS TO BE PROUD OF
ABOUT THAT COMMUNITY THEIR QUEST
FOR JUSTICE AND TRUTH AND THEIR
DETERMINATION. TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL JEFF ALL GENOCIDES ARE
RECOGNIZED IS CERTAINLY AMONGST
THE VERY TOP OF THE LIST.
I THINK RUGBY VERY PROUD TODAY
AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU WILL
CHOOSE TO SUPPORT AND COAUTHOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
THEY CAN IS FRIEDMAN THE FIRST
ROLE WILL BE FOR CO AUTHORS ON
AJ ARE THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS
HOME AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS CO
AUTHORS ON AJ OUR THIRTY SEVEN.
AS FOR CO AUTHOR MEMBERS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE SIXTEEN NINE
CO AUTHORS ADDED WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON AJ OUR THIRTY
SEVEN.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
I SIXTY NINE.
NO ZERO.
THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
RELATIVE TO.
THE RESOLUTION.
WE HAVE MANY GUESTS WHO HAVE
JOINED US FOR ASSEMBLY THE
ASSEMBLY IS REMEMBRANCE OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF NINETEEN
FIFTEEN AND MISTER THIS YEAR AND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MY GAS
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARMENIAN LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO INTRODUCE PROFESSOR
RICHARD OF AN FCM.
REYES BY SURVIVORS OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE PROFESSOR
HOVHANNISYAN HAS SPENT HIS
CAREER ADVANCING ARMENIAN
STUDIES HE IS ONE OF THE LEADING
EXPERTS ON THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
WHO FOUNDED. THE ARMENIAN
STUDIES PROGRAM AT UCLA AND IS
AN ADJUNCT PROFESSOR AT USC
WHERE FOR SEVERAL YEARS HE HAS
ADVISED U. S. C. SHOW A
FOUNDATION ON ITS ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. TESTIMONY COLLECTION.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX OF NSC
AND WAS APPOINTED AS THE FIRST
HOLDER OF THE ARMENIAN
EDUCATIONAL FOUNDATION ENDOWED
CHAIR IN MODERN ARMENIAN HISTORY
AT UCLA. ADDITIONALLY
HOVHANNISYAN IS A GUGGENHEIM
FELLOW WHO HAS RECEIVED NUMEROUS
HONORS FOR HIS SCHOLARSHIP AND
CIVIC ACTIVITIES.
AS PROMINENT ACADEMIC WORK LED
HIM TO BECOME THE FIRST SOCIAL
SCIENTIST LIVING ABROAD TO BE
ELECTED TO THE ARMENIAN NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES. LIKEWISE
HIS STRONG CLASSROOM SKILLS
EARNED HIM THE TITLE OF MOST
INSPIRING TEACHER BY THE UCLA
SOME ALUMNI ASSOCIATION.
I SEE YOU AS WE RECOGNIZE AND
REMEMBER THE HORRORS OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. IT IS WITH
GREAT HONOR TO BE JOINED BY
PROFESSOR OF AN ASEAN.
SO WE CAN CELEBRATE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHICH WILL HAVE
LASTING IMPACT ON THE TEACHINGS
OF THE START TIME IN HISTORY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
DOCTOR HOGAN S. YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
MISTER CALDERON FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM SET OF IS SEVENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY THREE
EGGMAN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
PURPLE NO
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER MISTER.
FLORA MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE US A FLOOR YOUR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
PRIVILEGE TODAY TO WELCOME
MEMBERS OF THEHOLY CROSS
ARMENIAN CHURCH.
AS WELL SABRI HOFFMAN FOUNDER
AND DIRECTOR OF THE ASSYRIAN
GENOCIDE AND RESEARCH CENTER.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE SYRIAN
NATIONAL COUNCIL IN THE SYRIAN
AMERICA'S OF A CLUB OF TERROR
LA.
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THINK YOU.
AND I BELIEVE MISTER HIS AREA
AND.
HAS ADDITIONAL GAS AS WELL.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR HIS AREA AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER SPEAKER.
UP PUTS PART OF THE IDEA OF
COMMEMORATING THE GENOCIDE
COLLEAGUES. IS THAT.
WE DON'T JUST COMMEMORATE THE
SAD COMPONENT OF WHAT HAPPENED
WE REMEMBER THE HISTORY BUT WE
ALSO LOOKING FORWARD LOOK AT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE ADVANCED THE ISSUE. OF
MAN'S INHUMANITY TO MAN AND
CORRECTING THOSE ISSUES
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO.
RECOGNIZE PROFESSOR OF HONESTY
IN FROM UCLA. I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THREE
ESSAY CONTEST WINNERS.
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THIS YEAR'S
ANNUAL ESSAY CONTEST ON MAN'S
INHUMANITY TO MAN?
AND WITH ME ARE.
I BELIEVE TO OR ONE OF THE
WINNERS WE HAD THREE.
UNFORTUNATE ONLY ONE WAS ABLE TO
MAKE IT TODAY.
WE HAVE DANIEL CHARTER JONES.
WITH US AND WE ALSO HAD ADELIA
JUST THEN AND WARRANT ALFONSO.
WHO WERE WINNERS OF THESE?
OF THIS ESSAY CONTEST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EVERYONE'S CONTRIBUTION AND
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM
LIKE US TO RECOGNIZE A DANIEL
FOR HIS. EFFORTS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
AS WE CONCLUDE OUR CEREMONY.
A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS A MEMENTO
FOR THIS YEAR'S OBSERVANCE IS A
BOOK ENTITLED THERE IS ONLY THE
EARTH.
IMAGES FROM THE ARMENIAN
DIASPORA PROJECT.
IT IS BEEN DELIVERED TO YOUR
OFFICES.
MEMBERS AND GAS
ARE INVITED TO VISIT THE SPECIAL
EXHIBIT.
ON THE SECOND FLOOR ROTUNDA.
IN THE CAPITAL.
MEMBERS I HAVE YOUR ATTENTION WE
WILL NOW OBSERVE.
MEMBERS.
WE WILL NOW OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
IN REMEMBRANCE OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES.
DURING THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. OF
NINETEEN.
FIFTEEN.
PLEASE STAND
.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE AT THE MOMENTS TWENTY
FOUR NINETY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS NINETEEN NINETY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX AT THE MOMENT
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR THE MOMENTS
TWENTY. NINETY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
THIRTEEN THROUGH SEVENTEEN.
WILL BE CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
.
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE WILL
MOVE BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
FILE.
THIS WILL BE ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TO PASS AND RETAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP.
THIS IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY ONE.
THREE AND THE CLERK ROLE READ
WITH AMENDMENTS.
SOME THEY BALK TWENTY ONE OH
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA.
MISTER GLORIA ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE OH THREE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
AND THEY ADD CO AUTHORS I ASK
THESE AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED IN
THE BILL BE SET OUT TO PRINT IN
BE PLACED BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
SOME.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY DAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL'S
OUTSPRINTED BACK ON FILE.
FINAL LAB THIS NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE PASSED TO
RETAIN ILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
THIS IS A BE TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN. CORPORATE WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME A
MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER. MISS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER ON THE
AMENDMENTS
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN OUR TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND SOLVE AN ISSUE
RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE MEN
MEASUREMENTS BE ADOPTED THE BILL
BE SENT OUT TO PRINT PLACE BACK
ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER WEIRD FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN. AB
TWENTY TWO.
THIRTEEN THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN BY SELLING MEMBER
COOLEY AND ACTUALLY THE FIREARMS
CLAIM THAT URGENCY THERE UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER COOLEY.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN.
AS A MEASURE RELATED AMMUNITION
VENDORS
BUT MORE BROADLY IT FURTHERS
PUBLIC SAFETY.
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE PASSED
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND
OTHER BILLS SO. WHAT'S THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW. HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY UPDATED AND TIGHT
THE RULES REGARDING WHO CAN BUY
AMMUNITION.
AND UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
THIS IS THAT.
STATE LOCAL AGENCIES SECURITY
SERVICES THAT HAVE.
.
PROCUREMENT UNITS THAT PURCHASE
AMMUNITION SUPPORT THOSE
FUNCTIONS.
FALL OUTSIDE THE FACE TO FACE
DELIVER REQUIREMENTS OF
AMMUNITION THIS MEASURE WILL
ALLOW THAT TYPE OF INTERACTION
WITH. A FEDERAL STATE LOCAL OR
SECURITY SERVICE LICENSE TO SAY
THE CALIFORNIA THE BUYS
AMMUNITION ON A. WHOLESALE BASIS
IN FURTHERANCE OF THEIR SECURITY
FUNCTION.
A WILL BE ABLE TO DO SO WITHOUT
RUNNING AFOUL OF THE LAW
REQUIRING FACE TO FACE
TRANSACTIONS.
THE BILL IS UNOPPOSED.
HAS BI PARTISAN SUPPORT EVERY
CHRISTIAN RIGHT VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS COOLEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLARK CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
I SIX FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY AND I SIX FIVE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE BILL.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT.
AB TWENTY TO. EIGHTY SIX.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHEN AND
ACTING CIVIL ACTIONS. THAT THE
CHEN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIX
THE BILL I RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THE HOURS
IN WHICH PROCESS SERVERS
CONSERVE SOMEONE.
THE CURRENT EIGHT AM TO SIX PM
TO SEVEN AM TO NINE PM THIS TIME
FRAME WOULD ONLY BE FOR THE
PROCESS SERVER WILL HOPE THE
RELIABILITY. OF SOMEONE BEING
HOME DURING THE ALLOTTED
TIMEFRAME.
AGAIN THIS BILL HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN C. NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK LIBERAL. ON EVERY SHOW WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
TYLER. AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP A FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY TWO.
BY MISTER O'DONNELL THIS IS H.
R..
NINETY FOUR CORKERY HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY FOR BY FAMILY
O'DONNELL RELATIVE TO SCHOOL BUS
DRIVER DAY.
MISTER. O'DONNELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT HR NINETY FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZES APRIL TWENTY FOURTH.
AS SCHOOL BUS DRIVER DAY.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS IN
THE COUNTRY.
PROVIDING SERVICE TO NEARLY ONE
MILLION STUDENTS EVERYDAY.
THIS SYSTEM IS SUPPORTED BY THE
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS.
THESE DRIVERS HAVE THE MOST
RIGID TRAINING REQUIREMENTS OF
ANY COMMERCIAL DRIVER IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT SCHOOL BUSES ARE
STATISTICALLY THE SAY THIS
VEHICLE ON THE ROAD BY ANY
STANDARD.
BY ENSURING THE SAFE DELIVERY OF
OUR STUDENTS EACH DAY SCHOOL BUS
DRIVERS HELP KEEP CALIFORNIA'S
PROMISE THAT EVERY CHILD. WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THINKING THESE PROVIDERS THESE
PROFESSIONALS FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO SAFETY.
TO SAFELY A TRANSPORT OUR
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
I ASKED THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
SEEING KNOW DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MR O'DONNELL IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WILL. OPEN THE ROLL-ON
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR
NINETY FOUR.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH AS HAVE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED A MISTER O'DONNELL BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU AYE MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO A
WELCOME TO OUR CHAMBERS.
THE FIRST AND SECOND VICE
PRESIDENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
CHRISTOPHER BATES AND TONI
PELLEGRINO. AS WELL AS PAUL
BAILEY THE TRANSPORTATION
DIRECTOR FOR THE LONG BEACH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OR MY
OWN CHILDREN GO. THERE JOINING
US TODAY AS PART OF OUR
RECOGNITION OF SCHOOL BUS DRIVER
DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME.
EVERS WE WILL RETURN TO FILE
ORDER FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE PASS A RETAIN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
BY SOME THE MEMBER FLORA AND
ACTUALLY TO PARKS.
MISTER FLORA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED WHICH WILL
GIVE. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CITY COUNCIL THE
ABILITY TO INITIATE REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICTS THROUGH THE
ADOPTION OF A RESOLUTION.
THE CURRENT PROCESS REQUIRES
GATHERED IN FIVE THOUSAND
SIGNATURES WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT LAW. IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE THIS
INCREASES THE TIME ACOSTA
PROPONENTS TO INITIATE A
PROPOSAL.
SEVERAL COUNTIES ALREADY SAW
INDIVIDUAL LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS
ALLOWING FOR THE AUTHORIZATION
TO FORM THE SPACES.
THROUGH THEIR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AFTER A PUBLIC
HEARING THIS PROCESS IS
CONSISTENT HAS ALREADY BEEN USED
IN THE FORMATION OF OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICTS INCLUDING
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS.
AND RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICTS THIS BILL HOUSE
SUPPORT FROM CAL LAUGHED GO AS
WELL AS MANY OTHER LOCAL LAUGHED
BECAUSE IT HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECT LAST YEAR I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS FLORA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
BILL.
CLARK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL AND
TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SIXTY TO
BUY SOMETHING MEMBER WOULD
ACTUALLY TO HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
TWO IS A DISTRICT BILL THE
SIMPLY CLARIFIES COAST LIFE
SUPPORT DISTRICTS ENABLING
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO OFFER. VITAL URGING
CURRENT CARE SERVICES IN A VERY
REMOTE AREA OF MY DISTRICT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEEM NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE VOTE.
IT'S VOTER DESIRE TO THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE AROUND THAILAND I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILEITEM THIRTY TO PASS AND
RETAIN. WE ARE FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THREE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN TEN THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN TEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN TEN WOULD MODERNIZE
THE PROCEDURE BY WHICH ADDRESS.
ARREST WARRANTS AND SEARCH
WARRANTS ARE ISSUED IN
CALIFORNIA BY ALLOWING A
MAGISTRATE TO ISSUE THESE
WARRANTS ELECTRONICALLY INSTEAD
OF OVER THE TELEPHONE IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO DO SO. THIS BILL
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK CLUB THE ROLL-ON SARAH
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ON TIE THEM ON I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY FIVE THROUGH
THIRTY NINE. PASS TO RETAIN.
MEMBERS RETURN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR.
THAT IS AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER MATHIS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THEM BY
MENTAL QUALITY.
MR MATHIS
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE IS A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE LITIGATION REALLY FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS INVOLVING THE
REIMBURSEMENT. CONVERSION
REPURPOSE SCENE OR REPLACEMENT
OF AN EXISTING BUILDING THAT IS
ABANDONED DILAPIDATED. OR HAS
BEEN VACANT.
FOR MORE THAN ONE YEAR.
GIVEN THE STATE OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE DRASTIC NEED FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING FOR OUR STATES WORKING
FAMILIES.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM.
CLARK WELL THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
A CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLLING TIED ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE KNOWS FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY
MISTER DAVID CHIU THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME EVIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN BYE
SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES.
CHU YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE PROTECTED AS
EXERCISE LEGAL RIGHTS SUCH AS
DECIDING WHETHER TO JOIN A
UNION.
WHILE STATE LAW ALREADY
PROHIBITS A PUBLIC EMPLOYER FROM
INTERFERING WITH THE CURRENT
EMPLOYER THAT WANTS TO BE
REPRESENTED THIS PROTECTION
DOESN'T EXTEND TO PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL WOULD CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE IF AN EMPLOYER
DISCOURAGES UNION MEMBERSHIP OR
OTHERWISE DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
A POTENTIAL EMPLOYEE DURING THE
HIRING PROCESS THAT UNDERMINES
THE RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
FREELY DECIDE. WHETHER TO JOIN A
UNION AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL WRONG ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE NOTES TWENTY THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WHERE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE.
AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER ACOSTA
AND ACTUALLY TO RECYCLING. MR
ACOSTA YOU MAY OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB TWO ONE
TEAM NINETY SEVEN CHANGES THE
DATE OF THE SUBMISSION OF THE
ANNUAL PORT FOR CARPET
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION. FROM
JULY FIRST TO SEPTEMBER FIRST IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE TIME
TO GATHER DATA DRAFT REPORT
PROVIDED TO ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR FEEDBACK AND THEN SUBMITTED
ON TIME TO CAL RECYCLE. THERE
BUT NO I KNOW VOTES ON THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS COSTA SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
MEMBERS VETERANS ARAB VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ANTI SIXTY SEVEN. KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY TO PASS A
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY THREE AB TWENTY TWO
TEN AYE MR MCCARTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO TEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE
THIS MEASURE THINK CLEAN UP
TECHNICAL BILL RELATED TO A
MEASURE FROM LAST YEAR WHICH
ALLOWS REFUGEES AND SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDERS TO ENROLL
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
PAYING NON RESIDENT TUITION A
DRAFTING ERROR LEFT OUT AFGHAN
REFUGEES FROM THIS MEASURE
COMMUNICATIVE. CHEMICAL SYSTEM
CAUGHT IT ONE HAS TO FIX IT TO
ALLOW THE AFGHAN REFUGEES AND
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDERS
TO BE ABLE TO THE ROLLER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND PAY NON
RESIDENT TUITION. FROM THE DAY
OF ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. QUIRK LOVE THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROADS HIGH
ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY THREE.
KNOWS THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOURS AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SEVEN THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACTUALLY MOTORCYCLES.
THANK YOU MISTER FRIEDMAN YOU
MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO RESENT AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN MOTORCYCLE HANG
TAGS IN ORDER TO UPDATE A
PROCESS SIMILAR TO THE FEDERAL
PROCESS FOR NEW CAR SALES. BY
WHICH MOTORCYCLE MANUFACTURERS
AND DEALERS PROVIDE MORE ROBUST
INFORMATION ON THE MOTORCYCLES
HANG TAG PRICE.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN
INSURERS AT THE PRICE TAG ON
MOTORCYCLES IS CLEAR TO THE
CONSUMER BY CLEARING THE
MANUFACTURER'S SUGGESTED PRICE.
BEEN NUMBER AND THE SUPPLEMENTAL
ADD ONS A DEALER MAY INCLUDE.
THIS PRICING MODEL IS MANDATED
ON THE WINDSHIELD OF NEW CARS
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE FORM OF THE MOTT MARONEY
STICKER AND SHOULD BE UNIFORM
FOR NEW MOTORCYCLES SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A GOOD CONSUMER
TRANSPARENCY BILL THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLES DEALERS ASSOCIATION
AND IS THERE PRIORITY FOR
CONSUMER PRICING TRANSPARENCY.
SO TODAY LET'S GO HOG WILD IN
VOTE I ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN.
SEEING THEIR REACTION OR
DISCUSSION.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE OR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU VOTE ICE FORTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE PASS
RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SIX.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY NINE BY
MISTER STONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE FORTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER MARK STONE
AND ACTUALLY TO THAILAND AND
SUBMERGED LANDS.
MISTER STONE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
HOLDS. VARIOUS PROPERTIES AND
WISHES TO TRANSFER THEM TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE HELD TO THE
PUBLIC TRUST FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
IT MUSTDO SO BY GOING THROUGH A
VERY LABORIOUS PROCESS. TAKING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THAT IS
NO LONGER NECESSARY GIVEN ONLINE
TOOLS AND OTHER WAYS TO MAKE
THOSE TRANSACTIONS PUBLIC. OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE CAN
ALWAYS WEIGH IN ON THOSE
TRANSACTION SHOULD WE DESIRE TO
BUT IF NOT AND MOST OF US GO
THROUGH ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND
CONTENTED GENDERS. THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES THE.
STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO DO
THOSE EXCHANGES THOSE TRANSFERS
TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ON THEIR
OWN WITHOUT THE LABORIOUS
PROCESS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES.
A RESTORED MISTER ALLEN YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
I WAS YOU KNOW VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
MAYBE YOU'LL MIGHT NOT KNOW WITH
THERE'S ONLY THREE PEOPLE LISTEN
TO THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
THERE THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF
THE STATE COMPTROLLER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE.
I THINK THEY TELL ALL THESE
TRANSACTION SHOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY TAKE AWAY THE
ABILITY OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE OVERSIGHT. BUT TO EMPOWER
JUST THREE PEOPLE TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS ARE ON THEIR OWN AS A
MATTER OF COURSE OF BUSINESS.
IS PROBABLY PRETTY BAD IDEA URGE
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ALAN SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK CLUB IN THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT
ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN.
IS AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SIX THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
SIX BY SOME IN NUMBER RODRIGUEZ
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS.
MISS YOU RODRIGUEZ.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY SIX
SIMPLY OUT THE SEPARATE TRUST OF
THE CCPOA.
C. H. P. AND POOR ACT OF THE
SISTINE LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO OFFER REGIONAL RATES.
AND VERY IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
MEMBERSHIP THEY CHOSE TO DO SO
IN THE FUTURE.
RESPECT YES RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
CLARK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF THE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE AND FIFTY.
PASS AND RETAIN WE DISPENSE WITH
FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE AND FIFTY
TWO WERE PASSING AND RETAINING
ON FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE.
AND ON SENATE THIRD READING.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS FIFTY
FOUR.
AND FIFTY FIVE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS A MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE MEMBERS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLL EYES SEVENTY TWO.
KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OH
SEVEN. I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO AS
UNABLE THIRTY SEVENTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR I
SEVENTY TWONO ZERO UNABLE
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE. BY
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO CYCLE TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR. I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO A SINGLE TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO AND
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY ONE.
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THEY GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION YOUR COLLEAGUES.
OR PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
IF NECESSARY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION.
SPEAK ON THE GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO MISTER
KILEY MISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR CHAIRMAN A
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS AND A
DEEP SENSE OF LOSS
BUT I ASKED THE ASSEMBLY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY. OF JOHN
HUGHES.
JOHN HILTON WAS AN AMAZING
PERSON.
WHO DID SO MUCH TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY? THE AMAZING PLACE
THAT IT IS.
A SWIM TEACHER A UNICYCLE
INSTRUCTOR.
A BOY SCOUT LEADER.
A HUSBAND AND A FATHER A MAN WHO
MADE SERVICE TO OTHERS A WAY OF
LIFE.
JOHN WAS THE VERY ESSENCE
OF A COMMUNITY LEADER.
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY TODAY
ARE IS WIFE SUE. HIS CHILDREN
JOHN WHAT HE AND JULIA. AND MANY
OTHER PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES HE
TOUCHED
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THE JOHNSON
RANCH BARRACUDAS SWIM TEAM WHERE
JOHN COACH THOUSANDS OF KIDS
OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND MEMBERS AND LEADERS A BOY
SCOUT TROOP ONE TWENTY ONE.
TRUTH ONE TWENTY ONE IS IN
GRANITE BAY AND JOHN WAS ITS
LONGEST SERVING THE SCOUTMASTER.
HAVING BEEN THE COURTS OF HONOR
FOR THE TROOP I CAN CONFIRM THAT
IT IS ONE OF THE FINEST TROOPS
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION AND
BEYOND.
MANY OF YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT
JUST ONE OUT OF EVERY TWENTY OF
THE NATION'S BOY SCOUTS
ATTAIN THE ORGANIZATIONS HIGHEST
RANK. OF EAGLE SCOUT.
UNDER JOHN'S LEADERSHIP.
AROUND ONE THIRD OF THE BOYS IN
TROOP ONE TWENTY ONE BECAME
EAGLE SCOUTS.
DURING HIS TENURE JOHN
PERSONALLY MEANT TOWARD TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR OF THE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX EAGLE
SCOUTS.
IN THE TROOPS HISTORY.
NOW THAT
IS A LEGACY.
IN TWO THOUSAND TO JOHN WAS EVEN
FOR THE WINTER OLYMPICS BASED ON
HIS SERVICE TO THE TRUE.
AND COMMUNITY.
A FELLOW SCOUTMASTER DESCRIBED
JOHN AS THE POLLS OF THE TREE.
A POSITIVE INFLUENCE WHO COULD
ALWAYS FIND A LASSEN IN ANY
SITUATION.
IN JOHN DOWNWARDS HE WON SAID
THE BEST THING ABOUT BOY SCOUTS
IS THAT ONE CAN ACHIEVE THE
HIGHEST ACHIEVEMENT.
AN EAGLE SCOUT AWARD WITHOUT
ANYONE BEING BEATEN NO ONE HAS
TO FAIL.
FOR YOU TO SUCCEED.
HE WILL FOREVER BE REMEMBERED BY
OUR COMMUNITY. AND IS
CONTRIBUTIONS BE FELT FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
MISTER SPEAKER.
I ASK TODAY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF JOHN WHO.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
HERMAN SPATS THERE WAS A
VISIONARY. A DRIVING FORCE FOR
HEALTH CARE AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND HUMBLE DONOR COUNTIES.
HE DIED UNEXPECTEDLY IN
PEACEFULLY IN GREENWOOD HEIGHTS
EUREKA ON MARCH ELEVENTH.
HERMAN EMIGRATED FROM GERMANY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE AND CAME TO
THE NORTH COAST IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN.
THE GRADUATE FROM HUMBOLDT STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH A MASTERS IN
ADMINISTRATION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WAS ALSO CONFERRED
AN HONORARY DEGREE BY THE
UNIVERSITY AS A DOCTOR OF HUMANE
LETTERS IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN.
HERMIT TOOK THE HELM OF AS A CEO
OF OPEN DOOR CLINICS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH BEGAN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IS A QUOTE.
HIPPIE RUN RAMSHACKLE ARCADE A
STOREFRONT.
IT'S NOW THE LEAD THAT THE
LARGEST.
THE REGION'S LARGEST PRIMARY
CARE HEALTH PROVIDER.
WITH THIRTEEN CLINICS THREE
MOBILE CLINICS SPREAD DROUGHT
HUMBLE AND DONOR COUNTIES THIRDS
SERVES ONE THIRD OF THE
POPULATION OF THIS AREA.
PROVIDING MEDICAL DENTAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
IN HIS SPARE TIME HE FOUND OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE RURAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AND CO
FOUNDED THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY
CARE ASSOCIATION.
HE WAS A SUPPORTER AND PROMOTER
OF TELEHEALTH.
I CREATED A CENTER THAT UTILIZE
TECHNOLOGY TO REACH PEOPLE IN
MORE REMOTE AREAS.
HE WOULD INTRODUCE HIMSELF AS
HERMAN SPATS THEIR RURAL.
I'LL HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT.
HE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY TO THE
REGIONAL STE.
STATE AND NATIONAL DISCUSSIONS
OF HEALTH CARE WAS A LEADING
ADVOCATE FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS.
AT IS MEMORIAL MANY PEOPLE SPOKE
ABOUT HERMAN. THEY RECALL THIS
LEVEL PHOTOGRAPHY. NATURE AND
HIS SIGNATURE BIRKENSTOCK
SANDALS PAIRED WITH SOCKS.
IT'S USUALLY WAR WITH EVERYTHING
FROM SUITS THE SHORTS.
THE USE WORDS LIKE OPTIMIST.
TIRELESS
PASSIONATE.
FUNNY.
CAN DO CHECKS BY.
DESCRIBE THEM.
HE DID LIKE LONG FAREWELLS SAID
ONE OF HIS* COLLEAGUES RIVER
RECALLING HOW HERMAN WOULD OFTEN
JUST LEAVE PARTIES AND EVENTS
WITHOUT SAYING GOODBYE.
BUT WILL SAY GOODBYE TODAY AND
EXPRESS OUR SYMPATHIES TO HIS
WIFE SCION. AND HIS DAUGHTER
MARIA.
WE'VE ALL BEEN THE BERWICK
BENEFACTOR FUHRMAN'S AMAZING
LIFE.
IN HIS WORK.
HE'S INSPIRED ME AND I'M SURE
MANY OTHERS FOR HIS VALUES AND
MAKE THEM OUR OWN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF HERMAN SPOTS
FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
AND MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WITH A VERY HEAVY HEART I ALSO
WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF WILL
RODGERS THE CURRENT MAYOR OF
BURBANK.
WILL PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK AFTER
A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER.
HE WAS REALLY ONE OF THE
GREATEST SOULS I'VE EVER KNOWN
IN A VERY VERY DEAR FRIEND.
HE WAS ALWAYS WARM AND WELCOMING
AND GENUINE VERY VERY GENUINE.
HE WAS A MASTER COMMUNICATOR AND
STORY TELLER.
HIS WAY OF ROPING YOU IN AND
TAKING YOU FOR A JOURNEY
WHATEVER HE SPOKE MADE HIM ONE
OF OUR MOST INCLUSIVE LEADERS.
HIT A REALLY DARK SENSE OF HUMOR
WHICH I ALWAYS APPRECIATED. AND.
THIS OF VERY MUCH LOVED IN THE
BURBANK COMMUNITY.
WILL MOVE TO LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND WORK
AS AN ACTOR IN A WRITER FOR THE
LA WEEKLY AND SEVERAL OTHER
PUBLICATIONS.
HE CONTINUED HIS CAREER IN
JOURNALISM AS A COLUMNIST FOR
THE BURBANK LEADER AND RECEIVED
SEVERAL AWARDS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
HE THEN DECIDED TO RUN FOR CITY
COUNCIL.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE COMPLAIN
ABOUT CITY COUNCILS.
WHAT PEOPLE WRITE ABOUT THEM AND
COVER THEM BUT HOW MANY
JOURNALISTS YOU KNOW? AFTER
COVERING A CITY COUNCIL DECIDE
TO TAKE THE PLUNGE AND PUT
THEMSELVES OUT THERE. AND RUN
FOR THAT COUNCIL BUT WILL DID
THAT I DON'T EVER FORGET THAT I
WAS ABLE TO MODERATE A FORUM IN
WHICH HE WAS A CANDIDATE AND HE
ALWAYS MODERATED FORUMS IN
GLENDALE FOR THE CITY COUNCIL
CANDIDATES. WHEN I WAS A
CANDIDATE MYSELF MY VERY FIRST
CITY COUNCIL RACE HE WOULD ASK
THESE REALLY HARD QUESTIONS AT
OUR MEMBERS SITTING THERE
THINKING. IF THIS GUY ONLY KNEW
IT WAS REALLY LIKE TO BE A LOCAL
OFFICE HE WOULDN'T ASK THESE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
RIDICULOUS QUESTIONS I CAN'T
TELL YOU. HOW ARE WE GOING TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET IN ONE
MINUTE?
SO WHEN I GOT TO MODERATE HIS
FORM I REALLY HAD FUN ASKING HIM
ALL THOSE SAME HARD QUESTIONS.
AND AFTERWARDS HE WALKED UP TO
ME AND HE SAID.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT EVER
SINCE I'VE BEEN RUNNING I'VE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT WHEN I USED
TO MODERATE THOSE FORMS AND HOW
UNFAIR THOSE QUESTIONS WERE NOW
THAT I'M DOING IT MYSELF. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
CANDIDATES GO THROUGH AND IF I
WAS GOING TO GO BACK AND DO
JOURNALISM AGAIN I DO A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY AND HOW I
COVERED THE CITY COUNCIL ON THE
CANDIDATES. IT WAS REALLY
WONDERFUL THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
HAVE THAT JOURNEY IN HIS CAREER
BECAUSE I KNOW HE HAD ALWAYS
WANTED TO DO THAT. SO IT WAS
SUCH A JOY WHEN HE WON HIS CITY
COUNCIL RACE AND BECAME THE
MAYOR.
HE WAS MY FRIEND HE WAS A ROLE
MODEL HE WAS AN INSPIRATION TO
ME.
THE CRAP PASSING OF WILL REALLY
HURTS ME AND I KNOW IT HURT SO
MANY IN THE BURBANK COMMUNITY.
BUT I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE ALL HAD TO
KNOW HIM. TO WATCH HIM SERVE HIS
COMMUNITY.
AND TO INSPIRE A WHOLE OTHER
GENERATION OF COUNCIL MEMBERS TO
BE AND JOURNALISTS.
WILLIS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
NANCY HIS DAUGHTER SARAH AND HIS
SON STUFF IN.
AS WE ADJOURN TODAY IN HIS
MEMORY WE EXTEND OUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS TO HIS ENTIRE FAMILY
DURING THIS PAINFUL. TIME TO THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY IN BURBANK AND I
THANK YOU ALL FOR LETTING ME
SHARE. A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WELL
ROGERS WITH THE TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MS FREEDMAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESK WE PRAYED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS TO
ADJOURN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
OF THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
CHECK IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY SIX FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE A. M. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS
RETAIN. ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS FREEMAN MOVES MISTER FONG
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL
TWENTY SIXTH.
AT NIGHT I AM IN THE QUORUM CALL
THIS LIFTED
START.
YEAH.
WHAT TO DO A VOTE CHANGE FOR A?
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE.
CHANGING IT FROM AYE TO NO
SHIRLEY WEBER.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE. I IT'S NO.
A ASSEMBLY MEMBERBROUGH CHANGE
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY SIX.
I TO KNOW.
THOUGH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BROUGH. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SIX
I DUNNO.
MELENDEZ VIOLATED FORTY FOUR A.
B. TWO TWO TWO SEVEN I TO KNOW.
THOUGH CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SEVEN ITES NO.
FILE FORTY FOUR BILL AB TWO TWO
TWO SEVEN BIGELOW NO TO AYE.
SO THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO.
TWENTY SEVEN.
I KNOW